this is the velocity under integration
integration and honestly compared to the
money that you just look at it's
conceptually quite simple because in
fact it's just an extension or another
application of something you already
know
maybe chain rule from differentiation it
possibly integrating so that's what
we're gonna do in Reverse okay so it
starts with a simple set up something
like this this is an indefinite integral
that's what this exercise focuses on by
the way for definite integrals you have
to add on a couple of things but we'll
see how we go for time and you don't
actually need it yet you'll encounter in
more detail later but I may have shown
you cos not that difficult an extension
he's the kind of question now how could
we go about doing this look at the
question as it is right now if you
really wanted to you could just expand
this theme right like to the power of
three you can end up with four terms out
of this new binomial you could do it
okay however as you've demonstrated
before expanding is like long term it's
not a very effective or efficient
strategy right because I could easily
change his power to something that would
make expanding ridiculous and you
wouldn't do it okay
so therefore how do we do it keeping it
in its factorized form and here's the
way we're gonna do it um as I've said
you've got many different days for
different things depending on when
you've got like things to use by
different people
this method reverse chain rule is often
called integration by substitution in
the same way that chain rule originally
when you first learnt it you'd say let u
equal something and then you would use
this chain of derivatives we're going to
do the same thing but with intervals so
he's the key you're gonna look at here
and you're going to you this comes with
practice identify what would be a
suitable substitution to make that will
unfurl this question okay now I'm going
to choose I mean in some ways it's very
obvious for this particular question I'm
going to choose x squared plus 1 as what
I'm going to substitute
okay father reason why is because beside
the x squared plus one I see X now X is
very very similar to the derivative of x
squared plus one it's not exactly the
same but it's only off by a constant so
it's very easy to work with
okay that's right so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna say take that guy and let's
replace that with you okay now if I'm
going to change that variable right that
kind of changes everything because you
can't just put human there right then
you're gonna exit use it a bit of a sort
of disastrous mess if you have it all in
X's that's okay if you want to go to use
you've got to go all to use okay so I'm
gonna have to change this and this and
this here's how I'm gonna do it
see how good DX there that means
differentiation or integration okay so
if I take you and I differentiate it do
you DX so I'm differentiating this with
respect to X what is the derivative just
2x right now I don't have 2x in my
integrate I don't have to explain degree
however I have X which is very close to
that all I have to do is divide both
sides by two okay so you could see now
in one fell swoop using this line here
up right I'm gonna be able to eliminate
both of these going to replace them with
their equivalents in terms of you okay
so now that I know this and this I could
say therefore this thing is equal to
integral off now first I'll replace the
x squared plus one that tends to be the
way I do it it's super my new integrand
it's going to be not XY plus one but you
cute there it is it's gone then I
replace my X right with this guy right
it's a bit messy but you'll see it cut
quite easily comes out in one there's
the X that was hanging out the front and
then there's a DX here okay now you can
see what's going on here I have these
two things can't
it's just like a fraction right like we
dealt with rise everyone before where
you've got / run and multiply my they'll
disappear and now you can see what I'm
doing is if I take that half out the
front just to tidy it up this is you
cubed
do you write so now I'm integrating with
respect to a whole new variable but it
follows all the rules that we know
before right what's the primitive of U
cubed u to the four on four you wait
we're we're bouts make do you the
subject you made here okay all right now
some people will do it like that okay um
sort of all right something like that or
they'll make DX the subject to get rid
of either of those now I've seen those
before
I think I think they're okay I think
it's a bit dangerous to throw these
around just as independent things I kind
of like doing it this way because it
shows I got it from a derivative right
like even though DX in to use do follow
a lot of the same rules as in all
arithmetic does right they also follow
all of them so that's why I kind of
leave it attached to its DQ as you can
see you're going to get the same result
it's okay but um and I don't frown on
that but I do it this way it's my
present okay I've got my constant flying
around there I should say that that's a
number not a it's a real number not an
actual variable and then just to tidy up
right my questions started with X's I
introduced you to make it easier for me
to stall but the question has nothing to
do with huge okay so therefore I've got
the 1 over a out the front for the to
the 4 and then what I'm left with is
this that's you it's a platform plus my
constant and I'm finished and just as a
quick note some of you might have
noticed hey hey hold on a second this
half that multiplies by this shouldn't
that mean that the whole thing is what's
Y by a half and it kind of does but you
know what a constant or a half the
constant is still a constant right it's
just a different one
can when its value is at the moment
because indefinitely I've got all of the
clothes things just by saying plus C so
that's why from this line to this line I
can be pretty relaxed with that pencil
okay so that's it it's not complicated
just a very simple extension and you
won't need it for this exercise but it
sort of begs the question right what if
I just suddenly change the question from
an indefinite integral to a definite one
okay now I have some boundaries on this
okay so obviously a lot of this is going
to play out in exactly the same way that
the original question played out however
remember how I said to you before you
translate everything here it's all in
X's you translate it so it's all in use
you see that okay well these boundaries
they are expounder is right in fact the
one in the two they are really shorthand
for x equals 1 and x equals 2 ok
in fact when I'm doing these kinds of
questions I'd write that for myself as a
signal to say hey don't forget don't
forget you've got to change them as well
right
so I would say well if I let this equal
this I'll do all my D on the ex-business
like I did before but in addition to
that I'll say look when x equals 1 use
equal to something else in this case I
think it's - yeah and when x equals 2
use also equal to something else I think
it's 5 in this case
right so when I go ahead and I change
this thing to all be in terms of use
right I think this is what I ended up
with before with my indefinite integral
well I'm gonna end up with the half and
I'm going to get two brand-new
boundaries that are you boundaries not
expanders ok so this will end up with
this like so and will unfold just like
it did before but now I'm going to put
these numbers you okay now it's worth
mentioning you're gonna get you're gonna
get a number out of this I think I've
already value interest if I'm touch my
numbers right I think you get this
okay I just really quickly there's a bit
of a strange question here in that like
why did I have to go back to X er but I
didn't have to go back to X here I could
just go from use and I could just
evaluate straight away okay you will get
the same thing if you go ahead and you
evaluate this primitive with these the
expander ease I said so if you get this
and this you get the same one an intra
goes back to that really awkward strange
the law that I gave you right at the
beginning that applied definite interest
but not indefinite ones remember right
something with respect to you or
something with respect to X the U and X
or the T or the feed off it's just a
dummy variable it's just standing in
until you can put numbers in it right
here you've got to come back to X making
it it's really just a number so whether
it's X or you or whatever label you like
you can just